all right
now uh ladies and gentlemen i'd like to
very briefly address something that
happened
on last night's show um it was a little
unusual
uh andy and i actually had a little tiff
um we actually got into it a little bit
had a little bit of an ugly
you know argument and well i understand
it made some of our viewers
uncomfortable and i just want to take
this opportunity
right now to apologize both to you and
andy to you
well i i mean i'm sorry too i'm i'm
really to blame for the whole thing
well whatever i mean whatever usually we
get along we're very good friends
yeah we get along and we just like good
friends we sometimes have arguments and
well for those of you who didn't see the
actual incident i thought
that this would be a good opportunity to
show it to you
just um just so you know what happened
so this you know you
understand what happened it won't happen
again dana why don't you uh
roll the tape from last night
the max weinberg seven max guys thank
you very much andy how you doing
i'm doing great yeah i'm really excited
tonight i think we got a great show
yeah i can't stop thinking about last
night's show it was
man that was so funny when deborah
norvell was out here and she like made
fun of your hair
and the way you looked andy uh you don't
you don't want to make me mad
okay you don't want to do that just
trust me
why i don't want to make you mad you
just just lay out oh
that's scary you don't want to make
me stop it you don't want to make him
angry stop it andy it's not
funny not funny
you're funny stop it you look like a
fool now
[Music]
look what you did oops
no i mean i i feel like a jerk now i'm
sorry why do you push me like that i
just
i mean i didn't know you'd go that far
yeah but you know you know what i mean
you know
you know i was bombarded by gamma rays
you know but i forgot
yeah well it's whatever now great this
is a good show
this is why
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry for you oh
good good it's it's done it's behind us
won't happen again right all right folks
uh stick around cause coming up next
the gadget guru andy parr is gonna be
with us that'll be fun
we'll see in a second